[Music]
happy birthday you're not special no why
was it off
if I think
you're not
[Music]
happy wares birthday everybody it's
Michael Kosta thank you for listening
this is very exciting we're on episode I
should have known this before I press
record can you believe 86 episodes can
you believe 86 people have worst
birthdays I can a happy birthday to you
if today is your birthday
don't forget you can listen and watch a
lot of these podcasts on worst birthday
calm please go to our YouTube pledge
pledge and plus subscribe yeah we're
doing video so that's fun and as always
you can subscribe on iTunes and we have
a great guest this week what if I said I
didn't every week you have to say you
have a great guest and really I know
some of you think it's [ __ ] but it
isn't because when you host a podcast
guests are pretty important and for me
anyone that says yes to me and sharing
their life in their worst birthday with
me is great so thank you so it's always
a great guest this week is Jimmy Pardo
do you guys know Jimmy from his never
not funny podcast from his many many
years of performing stand-up comedy from
hosting guest hosting Conan you just
know him from [ __ ] everything he you
know what I'm really pissed about in
this in this podcast I forgot to ask him
about the video he made with Todd glass
in the gasoline fight that Zoolander
stole I think I mean if you go to
youtube and you pipe type in Jimmy Pardo
Todd glass gasoline fight you will see a
video of them having a gasoline fight at
a gas station uh way before Zoolander
did it but I think I just [ __ ] I
don't know what happened he's a buzz saw
Jimmy Pardo and you just kind of get
wrapped up and I mean I forgot to ask
him also it's not called worst gasoline
fight podcast no it's called the worst
birthday please go to Jimmy Pardo calm
please follow him please check out his
podcast never not funny which I have
been a guest on a few times it's really
great it's a great comedy dude his wife
wrote on the show I hosted on II called
the comment section Danielle Koenig very
funny just good people folks I want to
thank Pidgey Bear who left an awesome
review on iTunes subject line misery
loves company on their birthday what a
great idea for a podcast thank you but I
like this sentence never been a fan of
birthdays so somehow hearing these tales
of bad birthdays is therapeutic and
downright fun to listen to
I appreciate that thanks for a nice
review on there guys feel free to leave
a review on iTunes and I'll shout you
out so thanks Pidgey bear I hope I said
that wrong I probably did I want to I
want to thank Jacksonville in the City
of Jacksonville Florida and the comedy
zone for having me last week very
impressed with the comedy crowds they're
more intelligent than I would have
figured unless I'm dumber than I would
have figured no they were great
audiences and fun and we had a great
time and I always enjoy performing in
new cities and new venues and that was a
new one for me I had a great time so
thank you comedy Zone in Jacksonville
this weekend I'll be all over Los
Angeles at the Comedy Store I will be at
the Hollywood improv I will be that's it
I think and then as with always all of
my dates are at Michael Kosta com coming
up June 2 through for the Laughing Skull
in Atlanta please come out tiny venue
really fun really intimate tickets will
sell very quickly
laughing skull in Atlanta June 2 3 & 4
maybe even June 1st that's all on my
website Michael Kosta comm uh worst
birthday com let's get to Jimmy Pardo
this is his worst birthday episode 86
every Thursday a new episode drops here
in the all things comedy Network
I'm Michael Kosta tweet to me at Michael
Kosta email me your worst birthday we're
starting to share these with the guests
I would love to hear about your worst
birthday Michael at Michael Kosta calm
or you can call if you'd rather do it
with your voice which is the thing that
people have and there
bodies to communicate information nine
oh nine five two worst nine oh nine five
two worst you leave a voicemail under
three minutes I will play it for the
guest so if you've sent me emails or
given me voicemails and you haven't
heard yourself on the podcast yet it's
coming relax we just have a bank of
episodes that we've recorded and I've
shared them with some guests and I've
talked about some of them but those
maybe haven't even aired yet so nine oh
nine five to worst or email me Michael
and Michael Kosta comm we love hearing
listeners worst birthdays because
everyone's unique and everyone that's
been funny and someone has been really
[ __ ] sad that I think we talked about
maybe two weeks ago where a man's mom
died and he fell asleep like where she
died and then I woke up and saw like her
lipstick on the pillow and it's like oh
that's a rough birthday but they're all
real and I hope it brings you some form
of entertainment in our lives thanks for
listening here's Jimmy Pardo's worst
birthday don't forget to go to worst
birthday com to watch the video I'm
Michael Kosta without you no one there's
there's nothing to do for me so thank
you for being here
bye-bye Jimmy Pardo is here ladies and
gentlemen I know it's a little a little
wobbly a little flimsy and I've know
I've noticed since we started recording
video some of the comments are saying
you had a flimsy it's flu is it yeah
I've also got a little echoey in my
headphones so I put in the headphones
are that it sound engineer well I don't
know if he knows about your voice but
you have an echo voice the way I think
in general has that echo to it
I've always had an echo voice I didn't
know that now let's pretend I didn't why
would it be happening right now like
this would be the time is it still
happening there we yeah there's is it
the headphones oh Aaron okay well blame
the cans I cancel as if I'm in show
business er well who says cans guys that
aren't in show biz yeah I think it's
young to say can yeah alright I'm
listening how many how many never not
funny have you done you know what here
we go I can answer that for the first
time ever really other than one we've
got our tada we recorded today our 700
episode Jesus Christ episode 700 today
Wow well you know what that is Michael
yeah that's
the cost the cost to doing business come
on my favorite thing of yours one minute
in and we already got a cost of doing
business
it shows on a fan yeah no that was very
nice well your wife wrote on the comment
section yes you did you came by quite a
bit I came by the office is quite a bit
a kid on one taping me because I can't
this has not do with you no I'm gonna
stand
television tape I sign my mom came into
town for a taping and she wanted me to
go see a mom you know the CBS show mom
yes over there the Warner Bros yeah
she's like can we can you come to a
taping and I was miserable it's the 6
hours and my mom loves every minute of
it every [ __ ] minute of it you know
what we went to things aisle addresses
yeah that we went to see the band
Chicago I I've seen over a hundred times
that is not a brag is just a piece of
100 times 700 hundred never not for
that's right yes so I took my mother to
see Chicago at the Greek man two summers
ago okay and I am friendly with the band
I was in the water memory and so we
thought my mother and they were like you
know what this is a time we can't have
you hang backstage because Al Pacino is
here during our break they're gonna
shoot a scene from his new movie so
during the breaks yeah it's an evening
of Chicago they do like an hour than a
break and then an hour so in the break
they are very it was actually put into
the movie it was good it was actually a
good movie I did oh go ahead and get
what it deserved
it's not called Bobby Collins that's
comedian but yeah something yeah where
he plays an old Neil Diamond sort of
singer okay and so he had to come out on
stage know this Pacino gene okay got it
she comes out and he's doing his the
song from the thing we're all supposed
to pretend that we know who he is right
up on the big screens they put our lines
okay this lasted 90 minutes isn't it
unbelievable and I felt like you I did
it but I think tickets to see a concert
yeah I brought my mother no the whole
thing I'm but certainly Mecca first I
felt like I was held hostage yeah you
are I don't want you're taking advantage
of me being here yeah but my mother yeah
who had never been there earlier loved
it she loves it she she's liked it isn't
that neat we got to watch out Pacino you
shoot a movie and you know what I'd say
yes to that if it ended after ten
minutes six minutes yeah maybe do it
twice the people in the Midwest
from Chicago that's right people in the
Midwest is your mom for Chicago
originally she lives here now okay they
think show business is amazing yes a
sink and we are jaded people now it's
the you know I do call these cans
I didn't I give her a Ron ik I just took
my son to see a taping of our friend
Matt azzaman yeah American Ninja Warrior
that seems like that could be fundable
it's not live it is not okay
uh-uh and they started 90 minutes late
because we had to do 90 minutes of crowd
shots yeah and once again I was like
yeah then don't get tell VIP to be here
at 6:30 tell me to get here at 8:00 yeah
because it was awful it's nine minutes
of me and my son yeah and I'm not gonna
be a dick and not know harder that I
gotta show your son that you're that you
are you're not the optimistic person
right believe in life and fun but that
would be annoying and again I felt like
you're taking advantage of being here
yeah I know I didn't pay to get in
well let's talk about when you were
doing warm-up that Conan forever and if
did you guys do that there's the beauty
here's the beauty here's the video I did
warm-up for Craig Kilborn back in 1999
and 2000 I thank you for saying the
whole year oh I don't know I love the
Callen yeah so you also call him the the
New York Football Giants I joke but I
will not because of that but I I do do I
do enjoy the Professional Golf
Association's now know this uh when I
did it for Kilbourne yeah that was and I
hated every second I was doing okay but
I was grateful to have a job jobs or
nice um and I did it for three I think I
did a total of three shows and after the
third it was decided mutually that I
should not have that yeah oh my gosh and
that was the hostage situation where the
audience can go to the bathroom no yeah
and they feel like they're it's not a
joke you can't go to the bathroom like
that mom we couldn't go to the bathroom
and they enter and if they let you in
the bathroom they act like you're doing
you a favor
I talk doing you a favor you a-holes so
kill room was a nightmare so when
offered me the conan job which was The
Tonight Show when conan moved here from
New York um I said I said no I don't
want to do it because I don't like doing
that I don't throw candy out I don't do
a dance contest there's a skill to being
a that style of warm-up
and they're like oh we don't do that we
learn from letterman yeah you come out
you'll do at the time it was only eight
minutes I ended eventually end up doing
like 20 something minutes because it was
fun but at first it was eight minutes I
introduced the band the band plays two
songs gets everybody up dancing yeah
time for the show that's it
no commercial breaks no nothing and they
do commercials and a halftime so doing
that go into a Conan taping well
honestly I mean this is early will be
the best experience yet you ever have
yeah so if that's your first one you're
gonna think love it they're all like
that so you were just doing you were
doing only an eight-minute set to start
at the Tonight Show
okay and then commercial breaks your mop
not even know how no that's a good gig
not one commercial rate the longest I
ever had to do at the top was 48 minutes
okay and that's because they sent me out
the long time at 408 and I was 42
because I eventually died at 4:08 I
would go out everyday yeah and it was it
408 to 422 I believe was that it was the
norm at TBS Conan and then but somebody
either a guest was later there's a tech
problem but I'm already out there yeah
so they can't go hey let's restart yep
so they're just like they just kept
telling me to stretch and and I don't
care well and you can do that right I am
lucky that I don't write jokes and I
could like why can you do that what
while I you know why can your brain do
that in other comics brains can I mean
every every comic can stretch a little
but it really seems like you you can do
that very long time I don't
again I can't write jokes I wish I could
write a joke I could be funny and and
there's no matter that means what I mean
you can't write I can't if you told I'm
by Convery sir yeah if you said to me
right now Jimmy go and I feel like I've
been on cocaine I can't stop talking
yeah oh I'm just I'm interviewing you
that's what happens haha God says if you
said hey and I mean this if you know it
I will give you $1,000 yeah and one hour
go to the other room and write me five
jokes using the first 10 pages of the
newspaper yeah I would come out of there
with my head held in shame but but going
up with no twit no dope with none yeah
with none and if they were they would be
jokes like this kind of professional
yeah they why does this guy have a
website yeah right what so what do you
do when you get out on stage you start
you start asking questions is that Alex
or I tell a story I then you know this
you know I tell us like I'm in my
standing up comedy I tell a story about
going to taking the other comic to a
movie yeah
and that truly should be a one-minute
story should I make it nine minutes yeah
okay no you add flavor to it sure so you
know I don't want to say I'm like a
storyteller that sounds like no making
too much out of what I do
was that always your goal as a standard
oh no it was just no as time as God
because I remember watching you many
years ago I don't even think we knew
each other yet at you you were you were
doing a set at UCB hmm and you were
trying to do jokes and you came out and
used for you what you were getting ready
for something and then halfway through
you said this is why I don't do jokes is
that right and then you started doing
what you do what I do oh yeah and I wait
and if I if I'm not mistaken probably
went from getting an OK response yeah
and I was like hey when it went much
much better that's what I eat but I
think you were you're getting out of
your comfort zone for some reason for
getting ready for something I don't know
what the [ __ ] it was but um so that's
just through experience of being a
stand-up comic you've learned to do with
that I guess so you know it was it was
late 92 1990 1992 is the night so 93 it
was actually that very week that New
Year's week I was in Indianapolis yeah
comic run into Chris Alpine was the
headliner battle and he for whatever
reason convinced me he was the guy he
was there was a moment that this happen
it was a moment Wow where I had heard up
until that you're the funniest guy
offstage yeah start doing this it's not
doing what you're stopped trying to be
Paul Reiser so and Paul rice was great
sure but I'm not Paul right you're not
Paul Reiser you're Jimmy Pardo so I
would I would kill offstage be the
funniest guy in the green room yeah so
Paul go Martin who's still one of my
best friends he was in my wedding he
would tell me all the time and
eventually he said it the right way
where I felt confident when Chris Alpine
would like he dared me to go on stage in
Indianapolis and not do my act right and
to just be me yeah and I did it and I
had some moments where it was silence
sure then two remotes that I killed and
it was like you know what this is an and
how many years in was that that was I
quit my day job in July of 89 okay that
was what
eighty nine and three and a half years
Wow so I mean so much of stand-up to me
is just getting comfortable onstage and
once you're comfortable then you can
actually be you right so you got to
finally be you after three and a half
years the beauty was like I was
comfortable from the get-go think that's
the one thing I always had good for me
yeah so I was a great open mic er I was
a really funny open micro that people
would come in to watch sure like oh
Pardo's up yeah let's go on and they
watch me as an open microphone and I was
like chances I be in the moment I would
yeah I would be like Richard Lewis
talking about the top of my head and I
would tell him the funny and then once I
started getting paid I felt like well
now I gotta take this ER tonight right
and then I socked yeah and then
eventually yeah like we say three and
half years ago yeah um when was your
first comedy set you said it was 89
well my first my very first opened mic
with in 87 and where was it that was at
the comedy cottage in Merrillville
Indiana Wow and I did three of them and
then stopped for a year okay and I came
back in October of 88 okay
and then I committed and then my first
paid gig was March of 89 and I quit my
day job in July are you good with dates
in general I just kind of remember these
because they were land Marty a yeah
little coach speaking of dates when is
your birthday
I don't know the answer yes that's that
good plan tell you my first stand-up
date but I cannot tell you what day I
was born my parents refused to tell me I
think it's smart save money yeah don't
we do it on your birthday July 28th okay
all right that's that's a that's a
Midwest summer baseball birthday is that
even right do you like baseball it's my
face America's past on it I thought I
was just looking at but when you I was
in my car looking at prepping for my
Fantasy Baseball Draft all for God's
sake you're one of these I love it you
up fantasy baseball brother 162 game of
it love ya love it love it love it
laughs and what if you change every
every game Yuri put a new roster I don't
even know how this [ __ ] works I have
been playing it since I know you like
dates since 1992 I joined that league is
still going Wow yeah Wow does your son
like baseball no I mean he likes Star
Wars than like science and [ __ ] right
yeah and he's into fencing in golf those
are the two sport fencing
yeah can you fence in LA uh you can't
even at the Beverly Hills fencing yeah
it sounds a lot answer that's really
it's Beverly Hills yeah I think I think
Beverly Hills Cop made even had a scene
at one of those you're right is that
right that's where your son senses so
what were birthday is like for you
growing up uh I think they were probably
like anybody else's in the seventies
yeah you know where you went the first
ones were at home
euro and and you'd had maybe eight kids
over how many how many you've you're a
big family no no no I'm only I'm not why
am I thinking that I don't think I'm
somebody else no I know your question do
you think I'm jimmy dore he comes were
big no I don't think you're jimmy dore I
know exactly who you are
you think I'm former President Jimmy
Carter yes yes and he's had some bad
birthday daddy a dad and a brother yeah
who had notoriety did he have a bad
brother he's a drunk
ah uh was a Billy Carter is it Billy the
drunk Aaron Aaron will find all this
stuff out for us it he didn't have to
look it up he nodded his head its bubble
what he also loves baseball so he's
probably and the Carter's uh uh baseball
and the Carters so don't know it's just
me my brother Mike yeah okay and he was
two years younger so you know we of
course were always invited to each
other's birthday sure as you should um
and then we would invite like you know I
think it was more financial than
anything else yeah you know you're
allowed to invite eight of your close
friends or sex or whatever depending on
what you were doing and it was like
you'd be at home and you do that pin the
tail on the donkey do all those and uh
uh and then maybe there be cake do you
remember being excited about your yeah
course yeah okay I did back then it
didn't matter that it was just at your
house and the same eight kids that you
played with every single day now we're
the same age kids coming over but they
get stopped a little bit yeah I guess so
and uh you know you put your corduroys
on instead of your jeans
I know corduroys do kids even wear
corduroy is anymore honey keep stirs do
dusters Yeah right I used to have a pair
of nice corduroys that my mom would make
me put in this wasn't even the 70s I
mean this was like 80s so but it was
still like yeah that was a way to dress
up without putting a suit on yeah you
know you put on a button-up shirt with a
pair of corduroys and you look like
you're going to church maybe in the
Midwest that's that's how I would do it
what does your brother do now now my
brother actually he is uh rehabbing he
took a his collarbone bro
yes oh he's uh but he's not in an
entertainment world he is not a UH is
that you know guy worked a man in
Chicago and a grown man living his life
was your family a storytelling family
was with it was what where would you get
the gift of gab from because you have a
nice gift of gab Jimmy that could be
because nobody else would talk is that
right all uh although you know I did a
one-man show back in 2001 uh and it was
we did it on September 10th 2001 Wow and
night 2 is supposed to be September 12
2001 something I forget what happened on
September 11 October 1 8 she's not great
with dates but something happened that
made us not through the second oh yeah
what it was I'll be damned Aaron look it
up
how much work goes in a one-man show and
you really just had only did one well we
ended up doing it like a month later
yeah and then uh it was a [ __ ] timing
the first night was so great that it was
there's a reason I bring this up the
first night was so great that it was
like this is great I can't wait
nothing can stop us now except the
greatest tragedy in American history so
uh the the name of that show was
attention must be paid a guy was
basically the premise was no matter what
I did in my life I was never kind of
rewarded for it so and and the premise
being that I talk a lot because I needed
attention I wasn't getting it I wasn't
good enough to be I was on the baseball
team or the basketball team and but I
probably shouldn't have been so to make
up for not being good I would talk a lot
sure
so take but to answer your question you
know my dad was a drummer okay uh Peter
Chris from kiss you familiar with my dad
does that your father no no um and I and
my mom's never know in LA when someone
Oh as a writer I mean you never know
like but I should have known that was a
joke my apologies no you have yours you
should know that I don't know I guess my
mom yeah I do everybody talk who was
funny in your family everybody does talk
do you funny uncle cuz like I think back
my my dad is funny you know it's
annoying I don't any embarrasses me and
I don't laugh at it but other people
think my dad is funny I used to think my
dad's when my dad is mellowed as time is
going out I don't even I don't mean that
negative
yeah yeah and my mom can be funny you
know I there's no doubt like my dad went
to see Steve Martin in concert sure you
know so he loves comedy and my mother
woke me up when I was asleep one night
on a Saturday night and she woke me up
to tell me to get up there's a new show
on called sctv so she woke me up at
12:30 at night that's another midnight
to let me know hate something of
interest is on I mean that affected your
life forever
yeah yeah and she would let me stay up
to watch Johnny Carson's monologue not a
dead word divorce it was my mom's up
dead okay uh am i so I was live with my
mom so during the week my mom and
stepdad would let me watch stay up to
watch the monologue God and then
occasionally if it was a comic that they
recognized name of which would be like
Steve Martin or PPR booty or somebody
they would say or Robert Klein certainly
yeah you could stay up a watch stand up
yeah
so Mike they were always made comedy is
pretty made really amazing it definitely
affected you it also is amazing that the
general public was that aware of the
comics that were on a late-night program
well at least my parents will your
parents were but I feel like you know I
feel like people recognize that more
than I'm a guest they was those were
only build those were the biggest shows
well you know I think about that time of
my step-brother Scott said to me once
when Letterman came out odd on Johnny
Carson came out on The Tonight Show and
he went right to the couch and I
remember my cousin I say cousin my
step-brother yeah family family he uh he
was I don't I don't I have to ask him if
he even remembers he had a reaction to
it where he I don't know if he was
annoyed by it because he was looking
forward to Letterman doing stand-up
right or if he was impressed but he went
right to couch right and he was like oh
somebody isn't there was stand up
anymore right and I was like and I
remember that being the first time that
that was something because he was older
than me yeah that was something like oh
yeah that's there's something to that he
doesn't have to prove himself right or
now he just goes uh but I was a kid yeah
when that and that and the fact that you
remember these comments also means that
comedy was important to you I I think
it's amazing in late-night show that
they just give the show to someone for
five minutes I mean they just say like
this is your show now right I wish I
feel like they don't respect the
stand-ups as much as they used to back
then
on news shows maybe it's because there's
so many shows I mean Conan seems like
everyone I know is done a Conan spot
it's like which is weird because there's
still only one comic week yeah but I've
been on for you know so so long now Joe
that's a lot you know forty weeks your
sets forty a year there we go
one of the hardest I've ever seen my
brother laughs I told you this in the
comment section offices I don't know if
you remember but you were warming up the
crowd and you said I was I was a guest
on the show doing stand-up and you say
we got a great comic Michael Koz is here
and they all clap then you turn to my
brother and you did the jerking off
motion and it was hard as I've ever seen
him laugh Jeremy Hots made him laugh
really hard once and that was ours ever
seen him laugh so it was very very funny
you were just so genuinely a
complimentary to me to the public and
then you were so complete opposite a
moment later to my brother and it was it
was fantastic you know but that also is
like that shows you how comfortable I
was at that job that's that I obviously
maybe that loose and not be worried
about somebody getting mad at me for
doing that or no maybe they would have
been but but I think I did it well we it
was it was to our family and it was
funny right it was for my brother and I
probably would have done it if my mom
was there I don't know the answer to
that like I would not know I would have
respect for your mother I know she just
sat through mom yeah she did have 6 6
and 1/2 minutes or hours of it um what
what of what of birthdays been for you
as a grownup I know we communicate don't
don't feel like I haven't read the
emails we've sent each other because
Jimmy said look what I really dunno I
don't really do birthdays but I want to
get into this because some people do
them and and very rarely does someone
just not really make a thing out of we
look where when you emailed me and I
joke I didn't you thought I was joking
I told you I kind of I kind of did thank
you I've been living in fear of you
asking me there's also people there
whatever reason people are always afraid
to ask me to do their podcast because I
think because I've been this podcast
pioneer yeah that I'm too good to do
them yeah and then when I see people
doing podcast like that jagoff hasn't
asked me to do it yeah it hurts my
feelings so when you weren't asking me
I'm like oh I can't one with this guy
yeah we laugh together why is he not
asking me yeah and then it was like yeah
I can't offer anything cuz I don't have
any exciting birthday stories well he
hasn't even to be a birthday story the
more has to do with your philosophy on
birthdays and there's a present in front
of me with a big
hi this is birthday show everybody Vegas
700 [ __ ] episode you did of never not
funny today
well what we do all seven who was the
guest was their special 700 guests it
was just our friend Jen Kirkman who have
yeah probably has a wonderful birthday
stories and do you try to book like us
perfect right
do you try to book like special guests
for know over because that would be are
you still would be on our business still
enjoying podcast I hope it never ends
yeah I love it
I'm you actually can make a living from
a pod can we have made a living yet how
do you do my co-host Matt Belknap and I
yeah it's fun it's a fun show it's uh
thank you
yeah and and how many you will do them
forever I will do it until they tell me
not to do it and how many are you doing
a week we do two a week okay and where
can our listeners listen to it are we
done no we're not done never not funny
calm seems like a quick wrap-up oh wait
I forgot you're the guy with no birthday
stories we're going to hear you I tried
to get the plugs in there organically
okay you know I mean I do yeah what what
do you do for your fit for your son's
birthday
now let me our hang on let me tell you
about my adult birthday yeah I'll tell
you about your doll birthday I I haven't
done anything okay I think for my parade
I don't know how old I'm gonna say I'm
on the show you can say whatever you
want no no no I'm gonna pump everything
down ten years for my 30th birthday we
went to just a small group of friends
and I and my wife put it together we
went out for pizza and just had a nice
time
where'd you go I went to a place called
baronies in Sherman Oaks California it's
a guy I love it okay so what do we do
for pizza in LA cuz people just crush
the city with the saying horrible pizza
is thoughtful pizza maroney's is a
square pan pizza okay and it's delicious
okay and so we went there for my
birthday ten years ago people really
hate on la for pizza I mean like yes I'm
telling this to the people that are
watching like it gets just an eyelid for
pizza but great doctor because it's sort
of that but why why is it so bad I'm
told by uh people who have flight from
Chicago yeah who wanted to open up here
there's acid with the water and then the
cheese in that says it can't mix the
same way is that is that is that true
because I've heard that water thing to
also maybe Aaron can can google that
I know there's any possible truth Aaron
should know doing that did that rabbit
hole so so that was a nice 30th birthday
that was yes and that was the birthday
that my a quick side story my friends my
friend Mike Schmidt my wife went in
together to buy me a alan banister okay
who played for the White Sox for a
number of years okay a Alan Bannister
game used jersey Wow
and it was up for auction and I kept on
commenting wow I'm bidding on this Ellen
Bannister Jersey as somebody keeps
outbidding me and I don't understand why
what the hell else was an elevator so
eventually they had to come clean and
they go it's us stop bidding bidding
copier and hitting your house off your
own wife so they got me that they
overspent on the elevators and because
of me yeah but that was very present
that's a good gift he went he was my
favorite player growing up was Alan
Bannister and where is that Jersey these
days so it's in a closet and i hang
being seen by the public guy
i wore at one time so he went vice
jersey jerk and I was like who's
Bannister who seems like that would be a
nice thing to frame and put up on in a
office somewhere Jimmy but would but my
wife and I share an office and there's
already enough sticks in Chicago and
journey I'm signed album cover wall she
does their one worse stupid thing on so
that was that birthday that's a good one
and then because I don't really do
birthdays yeah birthdays uh I just had a
big birthday yeah and my wife said would
you like to have a birthday yeah and I
said let's go to Verona's again nice ah
but we invited it ended up being 50
people Wow and it was a friends of mine
for like my friend Marietta came who I
dated back in 1985 Wow
she came and we're friends to this day
she and her husband and and then my
friend Pat Francis who was my roommate
when I moved out here Wow
he and his wife came so it was P and
then people that I then was working with
on Conan yeah so people through my whole
life were there that's great and it was
friends no family uh because my family's
all back there just in anyway it wasn't
about that was about friends yeah yeah
so that was a great simple somewhere
else here and neither need to be here at
this time I turned my phone off as a
professional
so that was that and I loved that party
and it was just friends mingling and uh
you know we ordered I think we ordered
too many pizzas yeah great and too much
cake sighs everybody got to take
something home small group although that
seems kind of big but but in general if
you want to have a great birthday what
we've learned is lower the expectations
uh get people that care about you and
love you and just put everybody in a
room
well that's ignited and I'll say this
much about that now the next day if if
50 people came at least 47 wrote me yeah
to thank me for inviting them and
everybody that didn't know other people
all said you really have the greatest
group of friends ever and I mean and I
don't disagree with that they are a
group of people everybody gets all I got
along yeah strangers we're meeting
strangers right and uh you know that's
tough it's hard to be at a party where
you're the the person of honor and you
got to entertain gw8 people but you know
show business so you don't have to
entertain anybody they're all you know
doing their bits yeah they're all
bringing their tired lasses having
people rent ice cream so you know it's
nice that everybody said that to you
because you know that there was at least
a handful of people that were like I
don't want to have to go to this
birthday party thing tonight but then
they went and they had a great time I
don't think anybody note that next I
feel a little obligated when someone
invites me to a birthday party no and is
this ruining it for you that maybe some
of your friends there's no doubt some
people did and by the way some people
couldn't come yeah and there's some
disco sound horrible yeah there's some
people that you invite out of obligation
yeah and and and then there were some
people that I invited that couldn't make
it and I was disappointed by 98 percent
of those that couldn't make it couldn't
make it but there were some other like
that's alright yeah yeah yeah it's okay
that's okay that saves us money what do
you do because I can see your wife
saying look do you want to do a birthday
guy no you don't really do him but you
can't say that to her you got to do a
thing for her we uh that's how it works
I my wife loves her birthday that they
all do she does want that day to be fail
I'll [ __ ] do right by they by I'm not
another the other sounds like you're
being I'm a dude on hi doc I'm not
saying women I'm saying significant
others your partner in love their
birthday is important and you got to do
a good job with it but we
both do what if you both do all of it
yeah yeah that's okay yeah that's okay
yeah I just I just take a retro nice
meal I've invited a guest on that hates
birth
I don't hate birthday I'm just kidding I
just don't nicely I'll stand
yeah why every year we as adults yeah I
have to make a big deal on yeah I don't
I understand you know like my worst one
wasn't it and it's not even my worst was
a lot some way to be nice if you shared
your were shut up no hang on 1996 okay a
time to kill was the movie okay uh I was
literally going to go to the movies by
myself yeah on my birthday 1996 and then
my friend my roommate my roommate yeah
we had just found our own way and he and
his girlfriend Pilar who is now his wife
they said what are you doing tonight I
said I think I'm just gonna go see a
time to kill him to kill and they were
like well we're gonna do that why don't
you join us
yeah so I literally was a third wheel
honored date for my first and they know
it was your birthday of course
they invited me back loser yeah that is
said and and it was okay and I was I was
I was grateful that they invited me yeah
at the same time I was also still a
drunk back then oh I think I would have
preferred to just go alone and then
drink yeah I mean we're there were there
definitely apparently you just you just
said you were a drunk where there are
some birthdays where you were probably
tossing them back quite a bit because
because because you don't drink now I
don't try seventeen over 18 years in
July by the way another question for you
yeah um I usually bring the guests a
bottle wine but I didn't do that for you
because you didn't drink but what's the
social etiquette on that because I
wouldn't want to give you alcohol if you
don't want to if you don't drink alcohol
but then I'm thinking well it's still a
gift and a gift is nice I I'm not one of
those alcoholics that would go yeah so
what are you doing right right we go hey
that's really nice you and I would bring
home and let my wife enjoy okay or quite
frankly I might put it in a closet and
go oh [ __ ] we need happen for that party
and I bring it to low yeah okay so I
brought it yeah well that's all right
yeah your company's enough haha so we
were talking about a time to kill how
was it
I loved the book and the movie was okay
and what would you say that's the worst
birthday that pops out I don't know I'm
sure one of my ones a childhood probably
broke bad and I just blocked it out yeah
but I don't remember any we on the road
a lot for your birthday oh yeah I would
imagine I was right yeah and that's kind
of sad yeah I remember I was somewhere
once in the club got me a cake which was
very nice nice um I'm curious because I
asked you about doing the road and you
said something that intrigued me and I
forget when it was but I I get lonely
out there uh-huh
you're there for three nights three days
but I also don't have a wife and a kid
that's making me go crazy and running
around doing obligations so but you said
you kind of like the isolation of the
road a little bit right you kind of said
yeah I do my thing on the road or I
don't know if it's you watch Netflix but
how do you pass the time I just I I will
go to a movie alone
yeah sure we'll uh I'll go to I'll go to
I I have this young kid named Ken
Schultz opening up for me okay
quite a bit now so kind of I will go to
lunch that's nice you can bring someone
that you like will yeah yeah that's a
big help huh uh a bit yes yes I don't
have the question mark of what piece of
junk is going to be ruining the crowd in
front of me I just had one of those this
week did you really and I I'm not going
to say where because I he was the nicest
guy ever you want to tell me off the
year I will tell you off the air but it
was just it just didn't work it was just
tough a lot of crowd work a lot of open
rhetorical questions that then trained
them to yell things out
and then I get onstage and it's just
like it takes me half an hour to even
get things organized here's a beaut mic
yeah Telmo when I was a feature act and
the first time I noticed it was when I
opened up for a genius named Peter
Gaulke okay and Peter has since gone on
to be a writer and stuff like that and I
remember watching him on television
going this guy's a genius and they asked
me do one opener for Peter cocky and I
couldn't wait till for a bit of cocky
yeah
and Peter is a weird odd comic very
strange very different uh but a genius
and he would bomb some nights and some
nights he would be on people's shoulders
it was one of those act Wow
so I was trying to find my footing and I
to this day I do a lot of crowd work sir
and I did a lot of crowd work in front
of him but I was so stupid that I didn't
realize that I'm sandbagging him yeah by
doing all this crowd work and mainly and
it all any young comic listen to this
yeah if you are a feature acting you're
doing crowd work
you're an [ __ ] because what you're
doing is you're sandbagging the
headliner of one or two ways if the
headliner also does crowd work well now
you've taken that away from you've taken
most of the best well yeah a lot of it
away take it away yeah and if he doesn't
do a crowd work you're setting up the
audience and exact what happened to you
yeah well now they think that they can
yell out and then when you're not asking
them questions that are Wonder an older
guy was talking was this guy's just do
it exact yeah exactly
stop it so then what should it what
should a feature act do whoo you know I
don't know the answer to that because
you were doing this material and you
earth well now you were but prior to you
starting this new you were doing
material as if I was no material and
then eventually crowd work yeah and I
was doing crowd work and and and burying
the headliners and being proud of it and
go out like I couldn't follow me of
course he couldn't you're not being fair
to him I used to think oh I buried the
headliner and then now as I look back
I'm going you were doing like hacky
gradual said that are always going to
get Road responses that are better than
the the headliner was more unique than
you yes and that but I was too proud of
the fact that I got bigger laughs but
it's like yeah but you don't know when
you know you don't know that and then as
you as you figured out and it was this
Peter Gaulke week that really I finally
kind of figured it out now the downside
is the exact what you just said yeah I
didn't have a fallback I had to do what
I was doing yeah I know Peter said
anything to you about it or anything
what happened yeah turn the corner yeah
and I I heard him talking to the
assistant manager and him saying he's
just the wrong guy to have in front of
me
yeah wrong guy and I remember getting I
took it personally turn around he goes I
went oh and he goes oh you she goes it's
not about you yeah you're great yeah
you're just the wrong act in front of
them yeah and again I I probably still
had my feelings hurt yeah I mean it's
but yeah it's that's hard to hear that
no mostly when I was like I could I'm
working with Peter Gaulke
get the wrong guy in front of me oh yeah
my first
weekend in Los Angeles The Improv and on
Irvine had me open for Brett Butler and
I had a great set and they called me and
they said we heard you had a great set I
go yeah thanks I went really well and
they said they've taken you off the show
oh Jesus yeah they took me off the show
I guess it was kind of the same thing or
whatever but I always wish Brett would
have just pulled me aside and said we're
going to have someone else do this right
but that's not what it's not how it
worked um have you since run into her
now and I haven't seen her I don't even
think she does stand-up and she's back
doing he's back at him so what's one of
your favorite clubs to play in the hole
in the hole the United States I will I
will name a handful if I'm ahead please
the comedy attic in Bloomington Indiana
okay never been that it's awesome it's
terrific
yeah uh helium in Philadelphia yep
helium in Portland Wow Ann Arbor uh yeah
your home club have you been to since
they've moved out love it I haven't seen
it yet love it okay great uh acne in
Minneapolis yeah uh the jukebox in
Peoria oh yeah uh and penguins in Cedar
Rapids okay uh there's one more that's
great and I can't pull it well you may
you may pop in your brain how often are
you touring about once a month okay on
in a perfect world once a month every
now and then it's twice a month and
that's only because like a club that's
wanted to get me in or one that I've
wanted to work will say how about this
weekend's like oh I don't want to do to
that month but I will you will do that
yeah and most of the time you're here
doing never not funny right yeah well
then you know for years I was with Conan
yeah and I'm lucky to still have a
development deal with them so I still
the draw a paycheck and and attempt to
sell TV shows that's great and it's the
greatest yeah that's the greatest well
really it's nice not great being told no
no I mean it but that's that's what we
have to deal with right you get know a
lot how do you how do you forge through
that you know I I think it goes back to
being you know I mean I'm not the
tallest guy in the world now so I think
it goes back to being a kid yeah and
asking people on a date maybe yeah and
being told no yeah or trying out for
basketball and being told no yeah so I
think I've kind of heard no more in my
life yes yeah um but we here know a lot
in this business yeah you know we here
know
Oh 99 times out of a hundred sure uh
which sucks yeah it's it's it's fit
you'd fail at failure yes actually it
really is but how do you how do I get
through it I don't know I think it's
just kind of what I've been used to
yeah I'm yeah I'm you I'm so easy to
know no yeah so that when you hear yes
it's kind of like well how do I react to
that exactly yeah yeah that's funny like
well I I remember they they asked me to
uh and I said but this was probably the
most vulnerable you hear me here we go
they asked me to compress record now
Aaron oh we started up yeah we are now
and I was going I get we get it yet
pizza not tell sorry um
uh Andy Richter had to miss a couple of
days at Conan uh for whatever reason
yeah and I was coming back from the
gymnasium and I received a phone call
from Mike Sweeney head writer and he was
doing he started off being funny on the
phone call and he said here's the real
reason I'm calling yeah uh Andy has to
miss a couple of shows next week and
Conan wants you to fill in his co-host
whoa and it was like this the call it my
way I mean that's are you kidding me
that's that's the life call right I call
what you think back on your life that's
the light right and it's like well and
and so like I got excited and then get
nervous and then when I found out later
that day when I got there and people are
like hey that's great news that's gonna
be fun yeah if you were like you know
they had options that you know because
the ESPYs were in town sure so they
thought about having it different of
course they had on there we have options
though but I mean I love it right I love
that some jaded right comedy writer go
tell him make sure he knows everyone
just let him be happy you're right make
sure he understands what we're doing
there you're right oh but but in a way
though by the way that's the first time
I ever thought about it that way which
is even funnier yeah but I did feel like
yeah they could have had Charles Barkley
on for two shows or they chose me yeah
Jon Hamm was in town they could have had
him so but by cohn is still wanted me so
I felt great yet nervous yes it's a fine
line like that filling in for Andy
Richter you have to be funny so it
warrants you being chosen yeah but not
so funny that it looks like you're
trying to take the guys gig but you also
only have to
were three shows to kind of do it kind
of be you only have two at-bats like you
kind of need to get on base yeah yeah it
was a weird sub baseball metaphor I
understand yeah I love the game I play
fantasy right ahead uh I'll go to the
World Baseball Classic I like the game
yeah so I was in the dress room area and
this is the formal vulnerable okay I
can't say the word but understand what
I'm getting at I'm in the drew I'm in my
dressing room uh and I write before the
show and I'm in my costume mm-hmm and my
suit I'm ready to go out and I gave
myself a little pep talk and I looked in
the mirror I went you deserve this
yeah enjoyed this isn't no they're not
doing you a favor yeah they want you
here I deserve this I think that is
warranted it's nice for you to share
that I think every performer has had to
have that discussion with themselves at
the point I think I'd I had never had it
you never had it
even though but you know I've done you
know a gazillion late-night shows or and
I bet you know done like half-hour
special I've done everything you could
want to do out the exception of David
Letterman yep uh and he worked the the
road yeah and I've done it all
yeah but there was something about that
I've done pilots don't you I hosted a
gazillion pilot now hosted TV shows this
was the one that just felt like wow it
all this is a this is a baton cord
O'Brien's trusting me yeah but why I
don't deserve this but I had a remember
yes you did you do work your ass off and
you you all those other [ __ ] gigs you
know you mentioned eight clubs that you
love there's 800 you've done that you
don't love yes that all of that got you
that either that chance like sucking in
yeah Traverse City Michigan yeah sure
and getting chased to my car and Saginaw
Michigan and just always mixes in
sucking I worked a lot of Michigan as I
was from Chicago but and I had great
show as a mission yeah and Ann Arbor's
one of my favorite kind of castles my
favorite and and Grand Rapids and all of
them but you're right all of those of
just bombing miserably and traveling and
waking up at 4:00 a.m. yes all that that
so how did they go oh they were horrible
but the point is this though they were
great they were yeah it was and I and I
somehow managed to find that happy
that's hot that is the Jimmy Pardo but
don't try to be too much and I found it
it's all molding a harder position to be
in
then if they just gave you the whole
[ __ ] right because it's like you got to
find this little like be funny but less
than Conan or desperate yeah they won't
look don't look like you're trying to
feel it but yet be funny enough that
weren't otherwise why have anybody there
yeah I mean the Internet's going to tell
you that you probably suck no matter
what
yeah I'm under some people gave me that
but I mean I don't Google my name
anymore things mark right smart Jimmy
Pardo I've always been a fan of yours
and the fact that you're even sitting
here chatting with me and sharing such a
vulnerable it's not even that vulnerable
you know it was a pep talk that videos
it's a nice that's smart you know I mean
I I used to see a sports psychologist
when I when I play tennis and they would
have you write things like that in your
own handwriting like you deserve this
opportunity I book you know when the
moment gets difficult I will rise to the
occasion I mean it kind of sounds crazy
like Tony Robbins [ __ ] but there's like
science behind it and that probably
helps you that science got you to what
ranking it's 864 eleven thousand dollars
over four years Jimmy it's still amazing
it's so great that still be proud of it
that's still amazing I say it on stage
and they laugh and then I scream at them
because I go it's literally an amazing a
life achievement I'm not like gloating
I'm saying you shouldn't laugh at that
you know then I think in a matter self
up yet for that right but I'll say this
it did it not in your defense but to be
more proud of you thank you think of the
guys that I went to high school with
that you went well there's no doubt this
guy's good enough to make the bigs one
day yeah I realize he never had a shot
never be a golf team like I was and go
this guy built East is the great I think
with Bobby's Bobby is the older brother
Bob T's is the best golfer I've ever
seen in my life yeah he could be a pro
and I realized he couldn't come close to
being a pro so for the fact that you
became der Rohe sure well it's like when
you go watch double-a baseball and the
guy throwing you know the pitcher is
amazing and you're like how is this guy
still not even making it better there
but and that guy was the Bob T steel Bob
T's aunty's yeah
he was the he was better than Bob T's
you know it's just it's so competitive
and comedy is is similar comedy similar
I'm probably ranked 864 in the world in
comedy I like hi I'm gonna have to copy
records County rankings are coming out
next week on this podcast where can
everyone find your tour schedule never
not funny
where can all have Jimmy Pardo calm
there we go and then at Jimmy Pardo on
Twitter and then of course never not
funny calm is the podcast there we go
please listen you guys it's a date
that's it we're done short where do we
keep it shorts I like yours where you go
there and you got to clear out the whole
afternoon you know animes insulting
you're lucky to be of a guest Thank You
Jimmy Pardo thank you
that's Jimmy Pardo ladies and gentle man
he's just a buzz saw
hyoeun absolutely he's a buzz saw he's a
great buzz sight comes in he looks like
a buzz saw the picture we took he looks
so intense it's hilarious uh he he's
just one of these unique people that's
in comedy right yeah the voice the
references he's always got these
specific dates and names Bob keel T's
whatever that's to be part of you guys
didn't really have a worst birthday but
uh but he shared some insights on
birthdays and you could tell that maybe
lost some birthdays to the boos I could
I bet and that may have happened well I
want to get into that but you could kind
of tell no no we're not going there
he's one of my favorites please check
out Jimmy Pardo calm and listen to his
podcasts been 700 episodes it's super
super fun it's if you enjoyed that
interview and you got a little bit of
taste of Jimmy listen to his podcast and
it's like references and rants and it's
just fantastic it's a great great
podcast this is the worst birthday
podcast you guys you can check us out at
worst birthday calm you can see the
videos now in our YouTube page just go
to worst birthday com it's all there if
you do some Amazon shopping go to worst
birthday com click on the amazon banner
that helps us out
as always my all of my live dates are at
Michael Kosta calm if I've if I set it a
little bit off today it's because I just
arrived from LAX
uh we get to Detroit we spray the
airplane with de-icer we go wait for two
and a half hours on the runway go back
to the gate spray ice [ __ ] on it again
fly to LA land in LA wait for 80 minutes
in LA so I'm a little off today but
nothing stops the worst birthday podcast
every Thursday guys we're on the all
things comedy network this is Michael
Kosta please email me Michael at Michael
Kosta comm also I forgot Erin if you
want to be on this podcast if you want
to share your worst birthday with us
call 909 five to worst nine oh nine five
two nine six seven seven eight and you
get three minutes to record your worst
birthday and we will share them to all
the listeners and with the guests nine
oh nine five two worst hey this is
Michael Kosta thanks for sharing your
worst birthday